l'idée pour le travail collectif que
nous faisons merci la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre vigier
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire de la
ruralité et des collectivités locales
monsieur le ministre le monde rural est
exaspérée d'être déconnecté nous les
ruraux notre téléphone portable ne capte
pas pas parce que nous sommes dans les
tunnels du métro non nous les ruraux
notre téléphone ne capte pas parce que
tout simplement nous vivons en milieu
rural vous le savez le programme zones
blanches est insuffisant car de
nombreuses zones ne sont pas couvertes
par ailleurs la loi macron de 2015
prévoit qu'une partie de ce plan soit
réalisé avant le 31 décembre 2016
qu'en est il quant aux crédits inscrits
au projet de loi de finances 2010 sept
sites mobiles stratégique
ils ne sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux
les élus locaux le dénonce enfin
monsieur le ministre
ces plans d'action ne sont que l'arbre
qui cache la forêt aujourd'hui une
partie importante des territoires ruraux
et mal couvertes ou non couvertes et il
n'y pas de plan d'action pour eux
comment voulez vous assurez le
développement de nos territoires ruraux
avec une couverture en téléphonie mobile
insuffisante
alors monsieur le ministre à quand la
connexion du monde rural pour que nous
ne soyons plus les oubliés de la
république
merci si la parole est un monsieur
jean-michel bagley ministre aménagement
du territoire de la ruralité des
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le président monsieur mesdames
et messieurs député monsieur les
et jean pierre vigier
nous venons ensemble il y a quelques
semaines à peine
dans cet hémicycle d'avoir ce débat
concernant la loi montagne mais bien
naturellement cette couleur dit
spécifiques s'appliquent aussi à
l'ensemble de la ruralité
les quatre priorités que nous avons
matière d'aménagement un territoire sans
le retour des services publics dans ces
zones nous y répondons avec les maisons
de services au public la santé de
proximité les souhaits nous y répondons
avec les maisons de santé
le numérique nous y répondons avec le
plan france très haut débit et enfin
naturellement vous avez raison la
réduction de la fracture téléphonique
il faut quand même reconnaître qu'il
reste à faire un peu chez original c'est
que lorsque les fréquences ont été
vendus aux opérateurs l'état c'était
votre majorité a remarquablement et il
faut vous en complimenter négocier le
prix de vente mais on a oublié de dd
d'imposer à ses opérateurs un cahier des
charges pour l'aménagement du territoire
alors aujourd'hui je confirme que la loi
macro sera appliquée et qu'à la fin de
l'année
les zones prévues en 2g dans le cadre
macro sont couvertes
je vous confirme que nous aurons nous
serons aussi dans les délais d'ici à mi
2007 pour la couverture 3g d'un certain
en deux zones suffisante et que nous
allons avancer de 2022 à 2020 la
couverture en 4g
pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai reçu le prix
en soit yann au président de l'arcep
avec son directeur général nous avons
regardé les choses des cartes très
précises vont être publiés en début
d'année les opérateurs le sable monsieur
le député
rassurez-vous nous veillons à la réalité
et nous veillons à la réduction de la
facture téléphonique
merci me